[Music]
what is at stake now is that a lot of
crises are following each other in a
very very tight manner we have not seen
that before we have a financial crisis a
economic growth crisis with massive
unemployment a inequality crisis
we had the famous or unfamous climate
crisis with a lot of effects prices
follow crisis in a very tense way this
is not a coincidence
the media crisis is the global
capitalism which will make our situation
per definition and with a frightening
logic worse and worse year by year and
if we don't change very dramatically
we're risking that my generation's
grandchildren they will have a poor life
[Music]
social
[Music]
oh
is caused by the coincidence of two
factors on individual level it is what i
call the insecurity of livelihood in
security of jobs and security of sources
of income
on societal level it is the cuts to
social spending
the public services are under threat for
the sake of remaining competitive in the
global rush for profits our government
cuts both social spending and reduce job
security increasing the pressures on
everybody in society but even if we
become very equal and very rich if our
health care system is underfunded or is
completely trapped in considerations of
profit we will all be extremely
vulnerable because we would not have
secure access to quality health care
these are the drivers of precarity
nowadays
autonomous son in acceptable
let's take the full consequences of the
global greedy capitalism it will only
make the richer even more rich and
listen they are rich enough if i can't
say one percent of the population own 44
of all wealth in the world do i need to
argue more about stopping this
development
[Music]
from
up till this very moment it has been the
norm
that our policy is created and focusing
on creating new growth
if you can make new growth you can make
new jobs and when you have new jobs they
pay taxes and we have more money for
welfare and more people will be good
but the point is that this is not the
true picture if you narrow to focus on
the growth
question alone you're missing all the
other policies you need to do
to achieve these goals we must enshrine
them in law we have done it for the
climate goals with the climate law now
we need to extend this approach to other
policy areas our proposal is that we
need to develop the growth and stability
pact into a sustainable well-being
impact
this sustainability pact would be our
new political compass giving us
direction through mandatory goals
currently we have that for fiscal
objectives but we must put social
ecological economic goals on an equal
footing with the fiscal obligations
of course to really have an impact
policies must be supported by sufficient
funding and this is why we propose a
european budget where the eu
institutions the national governments
the parliament the stakeholders like the
trade unions or the experts they come
together to define joint priorities plan
policies and allocate financial
resources accordingly this internal
dimension must be matched by an external
dimension we can't establish these high
standards inside the eu
and then undermine them by importing
products produced by child or slave
labor or even products that do not take
in proper account the carbon footprint
all companies operating in the eu and
all goods entering the eu must abide by
the same rules so this is why we propose
a european responsible capitalism act
accompanied by measures such as due
diligence practices or mandatory
sustainability strategies
this has always been our agenda
inclusiveness fairness thinking in today
but also thinking into the future and we
need to revitalize this agenda we need
to pay attention to the jews
people that is already asking for the
great answers they expect from the
institutions from the great answers they
expect from politics and it is our
responsibility to provide some of these
answers maybe we are not going to be
billionaires all of us
i think
a smaller people are going to be
billionaires in the future but many many
more are going to have a good harmonious
quality of life for our kids and our
grandchildren isn't that
wonderful and much better than the world
we have